well hello gentlemen hi keisha
what's up keisha music friends
um good i am good so
let's start this off by saying idris
this all stemmed from a rap challenge
that you posted on instagram
when you were homesick with coven did
you ever think
like a full-blown collaboration like
that
no i mean not not at all if i'm honest
but to be fair you know
connor like as soon as he he was like
one of the only people to actually
go out there and and and spit a verse on
this beat that i made
and he killed it i mean like he killed
it he could he was the
like he wasn't the only one there's a
couple albums but he was the one that
really killed it
yeah and it just turns out that he uh he
and i have a connection to an old friend
of mine called warren brown who was
who was in my show luther with me he was
also an actor
so it was just like oh man serendipitous
that he hit me up on the instagram he
knew warren
and uh before you know it we just hit it
off so the magic of collaboration eh
totally and of course i have to ask you
covered wise how are you feeling now are
you experiencing any issues we were all
very concerned
oh thank thank you um no you know listen
i really feel
uh really lucky fortunate man i'm i've
almost sort of
renewed my my zest for life because of
kobe but you know i i i had it very
early
in its uh in its world uh domination in
march
i have i was asymptomatic and at the
time people
didn't think that that was even a real
thing and that was a bit of a
a jar for me but the truth is you know
my wife and i we feel good we've
uh had no ongoing symptoms or
or side effects or residue apart from
the mental strain of what happens you
know it was like
you know when when i first got covered
you know
it was almost like an instant death
sentence and you know
i was quarantined for eight straight
weeks without
being able to go anywhere so that that
you know mentally gave me a lot of um
i don't know residue i think i think now
like i've just you know i've turned into
this person who can just
who just wants to eat up life the whole
time right now so that's the only side
effect
you know just being able to you know
there's so many people that have lost
their lives from it and i feel very
fortunate to have you know uh managed to
get away
so i'm i'm very happy actually you know
yeah absolutely yeah um okay so connor
set the scene wake up you check
instagram
and then you literally have a dm
literally yeah
what went through your mind and what
were you doing i was freaking out
it's like man yeah so i i put like i
okay
i see idris he posts about his
experience he he has this
freestyle and he leaves an open part of
the verse
and i'm like okay now's my chance i
gotta jump on this and that same night
that i saw it i i downloaded the
instrumental
i recorded my verse i filmed it threw it
on instagram
put it up there in my caption i'm like
hey everybody tag idris like i want him
to see this you know
and i went to sleep that night nothing
happened but then that next morning i
woke up and he he he saw it and he
commented and he followed me and he dm
me hey man let's work and i'm like this
guy
i'm still sleeping i have to be
screaming right now no it was surreal
um and now here we are crazy oh my gosh
idris so how long would you say it took
connor to respond
[Laughter]
from your mind oh man yes good question
like he was like
honestly i think he did it in the same
day i did it was the same day
yeah how did he yeah he basically
yeah you know it's funny
my wife brianna and i had a date that
night and i i cancelled it and she
supported the decision she's like yes
please this is more important
like make make this happen wow huge
props to uh
my supportive wife or let me do that
that's a brianna
that could have gone a whole other way
you're telling me it was a risk but it
was
i think if i think it paid off that is
amazing so
connor um obviously idris was named
people's sexiest man alive
um you know he's a certified movie star
his amazing dj
but what is it like working with him
behind the scenes
what's the t on idris i know he's here
but ignore that
it's all it's all positive i i like man
i've looked up to idris for a long time
i started acting when i was six years
old so prior to music which i only
started about two years ago
acting was always my main thing and so
anybody who knows me will tell you early
on like you asked me who my favorite
actors were idris was always in that
list so he was somebody i've always
looked
up to um and then later on i found out
you know he was huge in the edm scene
and then i found out he rapped i had no
idea
it's like this underground talent that
he has that's so cool um
so i've just been a student this whole
time just like watching how he works and
this music video that we got to do we
have like the skit so we're like acting
together
like it's crazy the amount of stuff that
i got to uh
collaborate with him on and not only is
he just such a great dude
um and i'm obviously not saying this
just because he's here he's he's a great
dude he's a stand-up guy
um yeah and we have like a whatsapp chat
and every so often we'll just like even
apart from what we've worked on
he'll he'll send me stuff and be like
hey what do you think of this i'll send
him stuff you know
it's it's it's really cool actually he's
just like a real person
and that's very refreshing oh y'all got
a group chat
thanks we got a group chat i'm saying ah
thank you connor that's beautiful i mean
that's really beautiful but by the way i
i feel exactly the same about this guy
you know
he's an incredible actor i know that
from uh he worked with warren my friend
but
he's also like as a penmanship you know
when we talk about
hip-hop we talk about the art of rapping
talk about the word play you know what i
mean i think connor's
super nice and just pointed it out there
i think he's very nice
and i was you know when talent i i've
been a big advocate for new talent i
don't mean to you know
just say but you know he's new talent
emerging i've always been someone that
likes to champion people that are
up coming up and um i was i was i felt
my ego being stroked that he was working
with me because he's that good uh so it
was it was
great it was a it was a two-way you know
uh two-way bro ship you know
oh this is so cute
so the name of the single is courtney
cox
it's inspired by the actual actress what
is it about courtney
that you guys find so inspiring
i mean personally i my mom was like the
biggest friends fan and so i have just
like all these memories
growing up it was always on tv and um i
mean who who didn't have a crush on
courtney cox she was just
you know she's just very uh fun to watch
and hilarious
and so once this song was done and i
mentioned her in the chorus and
i remember actually i was talking to
idris because we didn't have a name yet
for the song
and um we were stuck between unorthodox
or courtney cox because unorthodox is
another word i say in the course
and he immediately was like no it's got
to be courtney cox like it just feels
right i'm like yeah i think you're right
and so
that's that's how we chose it only idris
could say that though because he knows
what you know what i mean like he's like
i can see where this is gonna go
you know that's true yeah that's true
have either of you worked with her or
better in the past
if i remember correctly neither of us
you hadn't met her either right now
no i i didn't know courtney i think you
know like i might have you know seen her
at a party you know what i mean it's
just like oh there's courtney cox but uh
yeah i know i don't know courtney and i
i remember once we
uh we decided on the song name and i
said to him really offhand i was like yo
we should shoot a video
and we should get courtney cox in it ha
yeah i totally died end of conversation
[Laughter]
and then next thing you know we're
really taking this we're taking this
seriously and i was like
yo i think i know someone who might know
her publicist i'm going to reach out
eve carter was like really i was like
yeah
that was it that's what happened next oh
my goodness so you guys
reached out did she say yes immediately
or was she like
she needed a minute to really digest
this
uh connor i think she took took a moment
but it was really quick actually because
like it felt it felt quick yeah
yeah it felt quick you saw my publicist
and her publishers knew each other
so uh and i think you know i sent her a
letter through the publicist she's like
hey listen um
i'm ages uh it was just a weird letter
you know i'm saying there's a weird
letter
i'm in this and uh i'm rapping on this
song and i don't know if you fancy
listening to it
i don't know what she must have thought
when she saw it you had me
you had me record something similar
you're like yeah just do like a quick
video one minute
and i'm like oh sure and then here i am
with my phone out like what the heck do
i say to courtney cox like i've never
met this phone
i'm in front of my phone i probably have
like 30 takes of just being like hey i'm
connor i
i rap i'm like i don't know what to say
and then we both sent our videos i guess
she heard the song
like liked us and agreed luckily it's
the 30 takes for me
it's the 30 takes
the right one no no oh they're trying to
get all the right
yeah oh my god that's hilarious um i
never thought i'd see the day that
courtney cox
raps just drops around
and i have i have a cool story about
that because that wasn't
was entirely her idea so idris and i
know when we first found out that she
agreed to wanting to be a part of it our
whole
like all we wanted to ask her was in the
video because we're shooting it in the
style of like we're on video chat with
each other
of just have her papa have her pop up on
screen freak us out and that would be it
and she had her own plan she's like no
no if i come in i gotta take jabs at you
guys and i also have a rap written and
in our first phone call she played the
mp3 over the phone and she had already
had it done
like she she is a legend all that stuff
is all her
legend she wrote the rap she did it
herself it was crazy
oh my god you guys know that you've like
totally set the tone now where people
are going to expect like the jennifer
aniston song next oh my gosh
go through all the friends the friends
mixtape
on a scale of one to ten what do you
think you think jen can rap because now
i just don't know
you guys are just setting the tone now
we need a friends right now
yeah yeah i i honestly think courtney
might have it man like listen
she she said she sent some some bars to
us
you know like she really did we were
like oh wow
you know she threw shots at us and
everything so she thinks she might have
it i think we had to turn it back at one
point
we had to turn it down like hey hey it's
all for fun
courtney yeah exactly like chill chill
chill
chill um so the video is hilarious and
but interest you
you're showing some skin in this video
so
what's the secret to being 48 and jack
like how many hours a day are you
working out like what are you damn bro
you're 48
like good for you i am 48 man no you
know what it is man i'm actually making
a movie where
um i don't i can't say too much about it
but i have to stay fit for this film and
um
and yeah i don't know i didn't really go
out to shoot a video and take my shirt
off
but you know what you're in the middle
video movie you know i thought i was in
the 90s i just whipped that bad boy off
and you know my cameraman's like yo you
look alright man just just keep going so
we just kept going um but listen i
i don't know man i had to just say
thanks to my mum and dad for my genetics
you know what i mean like it ain't
nothing
i really have to give it to them come on
now come on now
um do you have a cheat meal is there
something that you
go crazy with something you love uh
uh tequila can we say that on tv here we
could say that you could say tequila i'm
with you on that tequila gang
okay cool um
oh i think to okay okay um i'm
do we get to see more of your body
in the suicide squad
wow you went straight for it um
no suicide squad i have
uh essentially i think arguably one of
the coolest
um superhero suits you know what i'm
saying i i arguably um
you know we went to a lot of james gunn
who's incredible director went to a lot
of time to make a
a design that we think is going to be
you know
like great to watch and um super
entertaining to see me use
so uh yeah you know i i didn't bring i
didn't strip
down in that in that film you know so
i don't think i'm gonna be allowed to
strip down too many times you know like
i'm 50 and everything and keep my [ __ ]
on
okay i'm just asking what the people
want you know that's just all i just
need for the people um what's
next for both of you
dude connor what's next for you man
world domination
what's next for me man i'm gonna like
enjoy this as much as i can man i get to
like
work with such two legends and and now
i'm just gonna because
i've also had experiences in the past um
where you have something you're looking
forward to then all of a sudden it's
done so i really want to like enjoy this
this rollout and see how people react to
the song
and just keep focusing on putting
singles out like focus on music
the one kind of positive side to all
this covered stuff happening i mean
if there is positive the one thing i can
say for me personally is
um the acting stuff really slowed down
for me and it really allowed me to focus
a lot on music and i really
have a passion for it and i've loved
this past year of just making
music and you look where it's brought me
it's i can't believe it so
i just want to keep yeah i keep making
songs and yeah keep trying to stay as
creative as i can
while being inside yeah yeah yeah good
for you man i feel the same i feel like
you know um
obviously my uh film career i have some
really exciting projects i think i'm
gonna shoot luther the movie this year
i'm really excited about doing that um
and i'm again i'm still going to put
music out like you know i
i don't i don't necessarily have this
ambition to be this huge rapper i just
really enjoy
making music i just really enjoy the
collaborative process
i just enjoy being able to express
myself with in my own words so
yeah i i think a little bit of
everything you know and
hopefully just you know just trying to
put positivity out there not to sound
cliche but i think everyone needs a
little bit of something you know
just a little bit of something as i
think as entertainers i think that's
part of our duty is to try and show the
world a different perspective from what
the realities are you know
you